there's a tech incubator inside the
least likely place on earth San Quentin
prison
we don't have computers here much less
access to the Internet but we're
learning to be entrepreneurs and
founding our own companies into a
program called the last mile in San
Quentin prison there can be no access to
the Internet not only that a lot of
these inmates have been incarcerated for
ten twenty or more years and have never
seen the internet San Quentin is a
pretty surreal place it's out of a movie
but it's not like a modern institution
in any way shape or form there's such a
fear around giving inmates access to
technology that has really caused this
system to totally stagnate
there are a lot of people in the prison
system that have an entrepreneurial
spirit where they just use it in the
wrong way over the course of six months
we each come up with a tech business
idea and create a business plan for our
final projects we present our companies
in front of a live audience most of us
have never done anything like this
before this event is called demo day
we start prepping for demo day three
months out we're gonna do our pitches
there's a diverse group here that are
all successful Silicon Valley folks
they're gonna give you some feedback
these are all passion project for you so
really start to take it from here to
here as you're presenting all right when
I got to prison and I was like what are
you gonna do you committed voluntary
manslaughter you shot and killed someone
known as my hired so I knew that I'd
have to become self-employed I wanted to
bring back the sense of community and I
think health and wellness is the right
way to do it because it gets people
thinking about their future and about
life the leading cause of obesity within
low-income communities is the lack of
access to healthy food choices feedback
on healthy hearts I can see you working
on your delivery and garros there
practicing in the pitch over and over
mining every sentence every word focus
is definitely not my father's barbershop
and here's why
today I'm how to just say something that
really resonates and is a story that
you're taking people through it was 12
years ago but my addiction to drugs and
alcohol has piled out of control led me
into a life sentence in prison friend of
mine stole a suitcase full of marijuana
out of my apartment I stabbed and
murdered in the past 14 years was
figuring out how do I got to that place
had disconnected myself from society and
disconnected myself from myself through
the use of drugs and alcohol this would
become the turning point
it motivated me to stop using and start
looking to fitness for a new way of life
hello my name is Christian Walker and
I'm the founder and CEO of Fitness month
this world of technology has been
passing me by in a lot of ways I feel
like Fred Flintstone and the Jetsons are
just moving right by me what are some
ways that you could see you formerly
incarcerated returning citizen get back
out there and start supporting the
millennial generation believe somebody
who comes out of a place like this and
survives this and has their sense of
values and sense about them
is a highly inspirational human being
that has a lot of things to teach and
share what connected yuechu personally
to say you know what it's not it's not
only my looming is not responsibility
each batch of a few that's what I wanted
you because I know the bad rap
look what Mike's dad of one what makes
that because I forget me the same way
they look at you and I got money I went
to schools better than this but it
doesn't matter I should be scared of
them taking my wallet with the state
when I walk down the street leash they
grab their purses their brother walk out
of my house over to the left two doors
down sister brother here both did
if you want that in mind over to the
right everybody in that block went to
Dartmouth for college Harvard for
Business School I went to the right and
so what made you choose unless there was
somebody in my life who cared enough to
listen to target my passion for studying
getting education didn't start until I
realized for the first time in my life
that my father really had no concern for
me I was participating in a crime and
kidnap robbery with my father I
participated in these crimes actually
just started relationship my father and
I were actually cellmates I had to
really evaluate myself do I want to
spend the rest of my life in prison and
accomplish nothing like he did to meet
the Internet is like a dream when you
can feel yourself somewhere and you're
trying to get to a certain place in life
right but yet you're gonna have the
power to do anything and have access in
anybody in the world
I have never been on the internet never
using a laptop or computer all of the
guys participate in social media that
voice has become so powerful they all
write out their blogs their answers on
core are their tweets and we have
volunteers that upload published
the good thing that I realize about the
Internet is we have the opportunity to
dispel myths
the biggest myth is that we are monsters
we have people just like them both
either been hurt we say hurt people hurt
people but we have this model that we
say heal people heal people the only way
you ever stay engaged you stay ahead of
the curve is to share ideas with people
just like when you came here right it
opened up a whole new world to you
when I found out about the last mile I
think that's the programming that's my
way forward Chris himself interviewed me
I looked him straight in the eye and I
said even if I don't get in I would
still love to be part of the last mile
because after spending seven years and
eight months in a system that is so
hopefully broken this is the best
program I've ever seen for anyone who's
incarcerated because a lot of
incarcerated guys really do have the
aptitude for being able to be
entrepreneurs but if you don't present
to them what the idea of
entrepreneurship is that you miss a
great opportunity I met someone who was
doing mentoring she said we want to come
in so I went in and I thought I'll do my
30 minutes and I'll get the hell out I
was there for about two and half hours
that hand started shooting in there
asking questions and that's what I
realized there are a lot of guys in here
with talent and dedication and focus and
all the things that we look for in
entrepreneurs they're sitting right here
in front of me my head was spinning as I
was driving home thinking it would
really make sense if we could start a
technology incubator inside prison I
said no way she said no effin way am I
going into prisons I did some research
about recidivism
what spending is in California on
prisons someone's incarcerated for 20
years not hard to do the math that's a
million bucks and the rate of recidivism
is over 60% so we believe that if we can
reduce recidivism by just 5% over the
next ten years alone we could save
California billions of dollars I
initially was looking at it because the
numbers till I had a chance to meet the
men and realize that giving back makes
me feel whole and that's what drives us
to keep going and keep doing it I was an
ex felon in possession of a firearm I
served as my third strike I was in
prison at 25 years of age with a 25 to
life sentence I spent the first five
years of my prison sentence and deep
deep denial about the role that I played
in getting myself in prison because
everybody else's fault on my own and I
could start thinking that I can
literally die in prison I could die in
prison and so I started making some
really fundamental changes in my life
more importantly you know what I could
do in the community that I lived in
which at the time was prison in 2011 we
launched last mile per second
July 3rd of 2013 I was released from
prison say your first five words thank
you god it's so good to be free that's
more than five thank you
in the last mile it starts on the inside
but then carries over on the outside and
that's really really important with
support system
we named it a last mile really because
this transition from inside outside this
is the most difficult part of it car
serration we sort of took it from
technology where the last mile is how
platforms sort of plug in to usage that
integration is so difficult and the
highest amount of recidivism is within
the first six months of release and
that's really why it's called the last
month the challenge that they're set in
the last mile is to do something that
involves technology something they love
and something that gives back commit a
bunch of bad decisions growing up I had
a brother shot killed a couple of first
cousins shot and killed I want to bring
some help back into the community and I
want to get people to see to strengthen
or me to say look you were strong as
your health
you know health is wealth we had a great
moment with Ray when we had got to the
point where he had to produce the
content that would describe the services
in his entire company and I remember him
just look at me and going we've got to
make all of that and we have a week but
you know what it was amazing he did it
Eddie was one that really struggled with
his business plan provides musical
general educational opportunities for
disadvantaged youth Chris that told me
to go with something that you're
passionate with and he asked me what
that was and I told him that it was jazz
whether it's through the melancholy
moved of Miles Davis or through the
sheets of sound of John Coltrane I want
people to feel my passion I got out of
prison and Chris asked me if I wanted to
pursue the coding I hadn't used the
computer so it was a quite a bit that I
had to learn it's almost like The Wizard
of Oz remember the guy that was behind
the curtain he was controlling all that
stuff nobody knew who he was or whatever
but his work was being felt outside
after refining our
and crafting our presentations we take
to the stage to pitch our new companies
we have five minutes to convince an
audience of VCS and fellow convicts that
our idea to become the next big Silicon
Valley startup
I would say 90% plus of the guys that
present have never presented to any
audience before and all of a sudden
they're presenting to 350 people many
venture capitalists our first demo day
we had the governor's wife in the head
of prisons and half the audience are
their brothers in SAP so it really
presents an opportunity but it's also
very daunting
and welcome you to the third last mile
demo day here at San Quentin State as
they accrue clean time members will
learn invitations to fitness events
where they can share in the experience
strength and hope of other members and
become part of the recovery revolution
of the fitness monkey thank you my name
is Raymond ho and I am the CEO of gimmi
gimmi lets you take a picture what you
want or use an existing image
the app will then process and compare
that image against our database of
online retailers
demo day was phenomenal MC Hammer was
there we had a super fun time because
you're shopping future is that's easy
yes see it snap it Gideon
thank you I got a little carried away at
the end of my demo do a little dance
giggling a challenge MC Hammer took
dance-off I don't think that time I was
too smooth for him intervention outlet
is an urban field mentoring service for
youth and parents willing to engage and
accept assistance with PTSD thank you
and God bless
recently I just had a successful parole
hearing where I may be possibly parolee
within the next 90 days
they looked at my business plan that I
offered you and they looked at all of
the slides that I had with my pitch and
because of those things they felt that
my parole plans were valid and my
support system guys I feel like a ratio
of hearts getting Griffin
kenyala Liao was a solid foundation so I
have to get some computer training and I
will also be taking a coding class
myself at least as well
I feel loved I feel appreciated you feel
tense I'm with my family with my loved
ones and with my life I'm with friends
that carefully a wit job opportunities
I'm WIC opportunity to have that home
alright so mr. Hill say your first five
words now hear this
my first five words is I thank God for
everything
and we got to get out of way for this
bus a lot of the work that we're doing
all of us that are out is to help create
opportunities for our brothers and
sisters that are leaving those
incarcerated settings and making sure
that they're all right know we're moving
forward together I've been fortunate
enough to work for a company called
rocket space and earn a position there
that allowed me to bring on another
fellow last mile graduate we're really
excited to have Caleb aboard with this
we have this thing called the Freedom
Trail where it will hike together it's
on Mount Tam which overlooks sounds like
so you've literally see where you were
glad you got your friends experienced I
know that Kristin Beverly one day they
want to retire and they hate somebody
that's willing to step up and take this
thing forward I want to be one of those
people the last mile began in San
Quentin in 2010 as a test look today I'm
going to let the results speak for the
back at San Quentin for the first time
since his release in July 2013 to share
his stories
ladies and gentlemen Crispino Kenyatta
thank you so much for coming out today
and supporting this program I'd also
like to congratulate the last month
class of 2014
laughter at this time had a life
sentence lived in four North 29 low it
was referred to as h10 93 today I'm
helping bring the future to market as a
team leader of Campus Services that
rocket space there's a whole world of
opportunities out there don't let
anybody tell you different
I just want to leave you all with that
god bless you I love you and stay strong
and keep moving forward ever backing up
heyyo